let me ask you a technical question
about cheating for at your level at like
a not your level but at a very high
Grandmaster level how much information
do you need this is a technical question
it's like so for me in terms of Morse
code and all those kinds of things I
would need
the full information so I would need
probably in order to make a move just
let's think about a very simple
representation I would need two squares
or the first to to designate which piece
and the second where the piece is moving
that's probably the easiest
what's the smallest amount of
information you need to help you
basically like a buzz in a critical
position that would be and what would
the buzz say it would it basically would
be something like one Buzz means the
position is is great and two buzzes
means the position is completely it's
completely equal or there's nothing
special in the position oh that's simple
just to know that it's great we'll tell
you what it will tell me that like my my
in with my intuition like there are many
times I've played Blitz online I'll say
something I'll say something along the
lines of I can feel like there's
something here like intuitively I feel
like there has to be a good move or I'm
probably winning there's something there
but I don't know that and most of the
time I'm actually right about it like
well after the game when I look with the
computer usually it's like oh I should
have played this this move and it would
have given me a big advantage or I would
have outright won the game so if I just
know whether there's something there
that's good enough that means it's worth
worth it to calculate here yes and I can
follow that intuition probably to
because what what normally is going to
happen in such a situation is there
probably are two moves or three moves
Max that you're going to consider in a
really critical position like if I feel
like there's something there they're two
to three moves so if I know something is
there I will I'll be able to figure it
out if I know that the position is very
good
okay the one Buzz for a good position
for the current position I just need to
know I just need to know whether whether
like there's a there's something really
good the position is really good or it's
it's just like an equal position or it's
just normal current position not even
future moves just the current position
there is a lot of Promise here yes okay
uh what about the reverse like
something's bad so you're saying if I'm
if I'm in trouble in a game yeah and I
and I I'm in the same situation
um so I'm in trouble in a game
it's it's probably a little bit more
it's probably like I would say three two
to three times where I would need to
know the source of the trouble yeah I
would I would need to know yeah I need
to know like is there like one move
that's good or there's there's more than
one move again how you extrapolate that
well wouldn't it be useful to know the
information that you're now in a
position where the other person could
create a lot of trouble for you so we'll
find that like it's out there find it
like if you look at magnus's games there
are a lot of situations where the
position is equal but there's or it's
equals one move but only one move if you
don't find that one move you're
significantly worse a lot of times
that's the case so like if I if I can
somehow know that there's like only one
move where I'm okay I could figure it
out yeah yeah that's so that's
one move is significantly better than
the rest
I mean I could give you like a perfect
example as I played a game in the
Canada's tournament last round against
ding Loren from China and there there
were many times where it was completely
fine for me but it started drifting I
started making some mistakes and I was
worse but there was one last moment
where I think I had one move where I
would have been able to draw the game
quite easily and every other move I was
significantly worse and I did not find
that move and I lost the game but if I
had known it would have been nice to
have a buzz right then yes I would have
known